we all know by now just how dangerous
the channel Crossing is freezing
conditions as you can see here it is
incredibly busy this is ship tracking
data that shows every boat in the region
at the time around two in the morning
but we can show you how the rescue would
have it by filtering out the boats not
involved here you see the fishing
vessels at the start responding they're
joined by that Lifeboat which left at
240 40 minutes later that Lifeboat is
part of it and we also see a helicopter
coming out from the UK we see other
ships a royal Navy ship French Navy ship
coming from France joining that rescue
effort and more boats continue to arrive
and depart and so do more helicopters
they're doing something different
they're not flying straight to the site
they're flying what's called a parallel
track line to look for survivors
traveling up and down the area with
search legs a short distance apart to
look for people who may have drifted in
the strong currents the search operation
continues over the next few hours now
today is the worst accident since the
disaster in November last year when 27
people died that came against this
backdrop of increasing numbers you can
see the pressure ratcheting up 2019 2020
2021 but this year it has hit a
different scale nearly 45
000 people making that Journey the
government said that people should take
safe and legal routes for immigration
but I want to show you a few big numbers
just to end and 90 of those arriving in
a small boat in the last year have
claimed Asylum that's 31
891 people there's a huge backlog
processing those claims but so far
according to the home office around a
third of those applying have been given
permission to remain so if you apply the
same rate of that holes that would mean
more than 10 000 people would be granted
Asylum as a result of crossing the
channel but look at this this is the
safe and legal route this is the
statistics the number of people who are
granted Refugee status through
resettlement from June 22 21 to June
2022 slightly different time period but
more or less comparable it is a whole
lot smaller ten thousand or so versus 1
600. now this number doesn't include
region specific schemes like Afghanistan
Ukraine and Hong Kong which have taken
thousands more but aren't open to all
nationalities and it's the difference
between those two numbers between the
ten thousand and between the 1 600 which
is why so many are willing to run the
awful risks we see in the channel